One of the interesting things about
healthcare today is the data is becoming
unsiloed and increasingly accessible.
So for example,
I'm wearing right now a little patch
will a company called vital connect or
if my shirt,
it's talking to my smartphone live and I
can look at my dashboard and my data for
my full,
an ekg which will show up right here and
it can track the trends and hopefully my
ekg looks like,
oh,
it's okay.
If there were any cardiologists out
there,
I could also see data about my steps,
my stress level,
my position.
If I fall down and I don't get back up.
Um,
the,
the system can tell that.
And this is really an intensive care
unit,
like type level data.
In a way it will be know less than $5 a
day.
Disposable Patch,
which can be useful if you're training
for a marathon.
If you're in a hospital and you're not
on a monitored bed.
If you're home with a disease like heart
failure,
that's a lot of data.
We need to learn to sift through it and
pull out the signals because no
physician or nurse is going to want to
be liable for watching your live
streaming ekg,
but is an immense amount of power and
data and we're in this era now of
creating digital health exhaust.
You know,
whether it's my smartwatch,
this patch,
my phone,
it can tell a lot about me,
my behaviors.
If for example,
you have a patient who's got bipolar
disorder,
you can tell from their phone whether
they're depressed or they're manic.
That can play a role in in smart disease
disease management.
We can take technologies like three d
printing and tune homebase prosthetics.
We can print prosthetic hands for folks
and legs and the developing world.
Here's mini me and my pocket.
It's a three d printed version of me
that might be interesting if I need to
make a prosthetic for someone who's lost
part of their face or I was at mit media
lab last week and met a young grad
student who diagnosis ain't own brain
cancer,
written up in the New York Times and use
three d printing to print a version of
his tumor.
Said,
hey,
you want a printer?
Do you want to print in my brain tumor?
This helped us surgeons do a better job
of finding it and removing it,
and he was proactive.
He noticed some neurologic symptoms and
pushed for his own.
A repeat MRI that helped them get
diagnosed earlier.
I have in my pocket and new
commercialized version of a brain
computer interface from a company called
interacts,
so this is the muse.
You can wear this headset and kind of
use this for APA.
Find Mindfulness and meditation and I
might use this to prescribe to a patient
who has anxiety.
Instead of giving them a drug,
I give them a headset.
Of course they can do meditation the old
fashioned way,
but this enables you to quantify it and
have a bit of a feedback loop.
So the ability to sort of quantify our
own minds with brain computer interface
like this can be used to treat
everything from ptsd to Adhd.
We're going to see use of video games to
improve cognition or to treat disease.
Um,
we're seeing fancy brain computer
interfaces from my Alma Mater,
Brown,
Brown university,
to enable someone who's quadriplegic
just by thinking to move a robotic limb
and those are getting smaller and more
integrated.
And so the disabled in the future may
just think move my arm and it'll be
rewired back to the road arm.
It benefit the spinal cord injury.
So lots of ways to take,
you know,
sometimes consumer devices,
crowdsource new apps and platforms on
these that will change,
you know,
neuroscience,
psychiatry,
and when we can pull this data together
will become,
become participatory in healthcare.
We can move to an era,
kind of like with Google maps,
you donate some data when you use ways
and Google maps through privacy,
your speed and your location.
But in exchange,
you can build a map of your,
of the streets and the traffic so you
get some information back.
I think we can have that same
sensibility and healthcare,
whether it's sharing your brainwaves,
your genomics,
or your wearable data,
while maintaining privacy and optin
abilities.
Using that information can give us
better public health,
you know,
better early signals if it's ebola
coming or the common flu,
or can enable patient groups to
crowdsource better cures.
For Crohn's disease,
for example,
there's this new world of the
microbiome.
We have 10,000 times 10,
10 times more bacterial cells in an
honorable in and on our bodies and our
own human cells.
We're learning that the microbiome plays
a role in everything from obesity to
inflammatory bowel disease,
like Crohn's disease,
maybe even some psychiatric disorders,
and we're starting to be in this era of
fecal transplants.
And you can imagine in five,
10 years,
you're going to get to and cocktail of a
probiotic that's going to reboot your gi
system to help treat diseases or prevent
them.
So a lot of these tools are gonna.
Enable the clinician.
You're going to be going to your corner,
you know,
pharmacy in many cases to get medical
care or telemedicine.
It's gonna enable you as an individual
to own your own health information.
There's already thousands of apps out
there.
Some are better than others,
but you can use those as tools to stay
engaged in taking your vitamin and your
aspirin or being on top of a much more
complex regimen.
And the challenge for all of us is to
integrate these in the culture of health
and medicine.
You have the best technology,
but unless your clinician uses it and
gets paid for it,
in some cases it may never be adapted.
The payers of the world needs to start
looking at how some of these can provide
better outcomes at lower cost and even
before they're fda approved.
Bringing these to market and I think
we're seeing many smart Pharma
companies,
payers,
physician groups,
think about how they layer these in to
be the disrupter and not the disruptee.